avec antoine fenaux bossoirs bonsoir ce
soir vous vouliez nous proposer un
exemple de la guerre agricole que mène
la russie en ukraine pourrait absolument
une guerre où la nourriture vous allez
le voir à utiliser comme levier de
guerre pour l'illustrer j'ai choisi
trois exemples qu'on a pu démontrer ici
info ou intox et observateurs de sept de
ses pratiques russe le pillage des
céréales l'ukrainienne d'un côté le vol
de matériel agricole et les destructions
des infrastructures agricoles également
ukrainienne premier exemple le pillage
des céréales d'ukrainiens va s'appuyer
pour cela sur le parcours des navires
russes et notamment l'un d'entre eux le
matros pausini choo part de cette vidéo
que vous apercevez ici elle est prise
par un turc alors que ce navire
justement traversé le détroit du
bosphore c'était en mai dernier le
navire lui il vient de sébastopol en
crimée et se dirige à ce moment là vers
alexandrie mais il va finir sa route à
lattaquié en syrie et ça on va y revenir
ces images elles elles nous ont été
communiquées par un groupe de
journalistes ukrainiens à travers le
projet cicrane que vous apercevez ici il
traque les parcours grâce aux open data
ces données disponibles librement sur
internet ces céréales ukrainiens de
voler est acheminé par bateau l'histoire
de notre bateau donc la première image
la voici celles qui le ce fameux projet
cicrane nous a communiqué ses le matros
pozo nietzsche photographié à quai à
sébastopol le 18 mai dernier photos
géolocalisées donc qu'on peut source et
on aperçoit vous le voyez cette brume
autour du navire c'est de la poussière
de grains symbole qu'ils chargent donc
des céréales dans sa cale ce navire lui
c'est un vraquier donc c'est un navire
qui est fait pour transporter dans ses
cales de grandes quantités de grains
deuxième étape cette fois le navire lui
il est en mer marine trackers qui est un
peu l'équivalent de fight radar vous
connaissez ce logiciel pour les avions
c'est la même chose pour les navires
marchands et bien il est rom il
répertorie ce ce navire au large de
sébastopol et sa destination semble être
beyrouth les na'vi en comme les avions
sont localisés sains avec des
transpondeurs et qui permet de les
repérer en temps réel sur leur parcours
problème est bien le matros pozo
nietzsche et des il n'arrivera jamais à
beyrouth mais encore une fois plutôt en
syrie planète cette fois nous a fourni
cette image satellite elle date du 27
mai dernier elle montre le port de
lattaquié justement en syrie et vous le
voyez ici on aperçoit un navire à quai
il s'agit exactement du même bateau aux
rails un avis russie transport du grain
depuis l'ukraine mais ce qu'il s'agit de
céréales volée oui vraisemblablement et
cnn l'a également confirmé de son côté
ils ont aussi traqué le matros pozo
nietzsche avec une autre photo toujours
du port de lattaquié que vous voyez
juste ici
le média américain don qui affirme qu'il
s'agit bien de grains volet donc on
aperçoit effectivement le navire ici si
elle ne nous en dit plus sur son
parcours pour expliquer ses sauts de
puce ces étapes auxquelles il s'est
livré il devait accoster ou en egypte
initialement ce navire mais les
autorités ukrainiennes ont averti leurs
homologues égyptiens que ce grain était
volée livraison annulé le bateau prend
cette fois la direction de beyrouth en
espérant livrer son grain là encore même
refus ils coupent alors son transpondeur
nous apprend cnn avant de réapparaître
comme par miracle dans le port de
lattaquié en syrie à noter également que
ce navire n'est pas le seul selon si
'crime toujours d'autres navires
notamment celui ci que vous voyez le
michael néo z chef un autre cargo russe
aurait eu un parcours similaire lui il
aurait fini son parcours dans un port
turc à iskenderun là encore plein de
grains chargé à sébastopol en crimée
occupy un commerce maritime de céréales
volé à l'ukraine donc mais ce n'est
qu'une partie de la stratégie absolument
audrey le deuxième axe de stratégie de
guerre agricole c'est la destruction des
infrastructures de stockage de grains
ukrainien toujours sur ces mêmes images
satellitaires envoyé par planète vous
apercevoir ici un silo à grains la
première image elle date du 8 avril a
été prise la rue business' et dans l'est
de l'ukraine deuxième photo du 21 avril
vous le voyez plus de stylo c'est aussi
simple que ça bombardements de l'armée
russe dont un autre exemple de
bombardements de l'armée russe dans le
port de niqab ra c'est près de nicolay f
un négociant en grains ukrainien a posté
cette image c'est lui qui n'ont qui fait
commerce du grain ukrainien de cette
image du bombardement du terminal c'est
un terminal de transfert de graines donc
depuis la terre vers les bateaux qui
sont 100 ch et la cheminée c'est ici un
terminal de transe de transfert de
graines de tournesol dont qui était
visée pillage de grains vous l'avez
compris mais aussi de matériel agricole
pour les alliés de la russie exemple
avec cette séquence que nous avons pu
nous procurer ici vous voyez vous voyez
on des images amateurs d'un convoi qui
semble acheminées sur des camions du
matériel agricole on a vu une
moissonneuse batteuse vous apercevez ici
plusieurs tracteurs détracteurs qui nous
qui ont été pris le 2 mai dernier près
de milito paul et devinez quoi audrey
ces tracteurs ont pu être tracé là
encore grâce à leur puce gps et devinez
on les a retrouvés en tchétchénie cette
fois là si vous voulez en apprendre un
peu plus sur ces pratiques de la russie
je vous renvoie vers l'excellent travail
de nos confrères des autres s'ils
avaient pu documenter plus largement ces
destructions de matériels agricoles et
leur pillage par les forces russes dont
conclusion vous le voyez l'armée larmes
agricole fait partie intégrante de la
stratégie militaire russe en ukraine
pillage des récoltes destruction des
cultures agricoles ukrainienne et vols
de matériel avec un but à faiblir
l'ukraine où vous l'avez compris et
enrichir la russie et ses alliés merci
beaucoup antoine penot vous restez avec
nous on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau journal